[Musique]
dans toutes les grandes villes au québec
brunch est une activité populaire ici à
sherbrooke on trouve une toute nouvelle
offre de brunch végétalien
et qui ont partagé le même balcon et
puis pendant la pandémie et on se disait
à quel point un soir je vais vraiment un
brunch gourmand vegan mais ça n'existait
pas le brunch dont on voulait ici à
sherbrooke et en anglais on s'est
regardé et puis on s'est dit pourquoi
pas nous et quand on s'est lancé
amélie et sofia ont donc créé songe un
restaurant de brunch végétalien dans les
cuisines la cheffe athéna fait goûter
son tout dernier test l'oeuf végétal ce
jaune coule en est une illusion fait à
base de tomates et de poivrons confits
au four ils donnent l'illusion d'un vrai
jaune d'oeuf
c'est vraiment bon ah ouais
c'est fou à quel point ça groupe
c'est vraiment délicieux bravo
l'alimentation végétalienne mais c'est
sûr qu'il ya eu aucune viande il n'y a
pas de fief pas de les yogourts tout ce
qui est produits laitiers donc pas de
fromage non plus et puis ça va même
jusque dans nos cocktails on va avoir un
miel qui est vegard ne pas trouver une
façon de reproduire un oeuf visuellement
un peu aussi dans le goût mais qui qui
fait à partir totalement de de légumes
ou de plans
elle dépose sur un mât fans anglais une
poêlée de champignons des oignons
caramélisés des épinards sans oublier
les jambes ou un plat tout végétal une
petite digne en grec qui rappelle un peu
le blanc d'oeuf
tout comme ses gaufres au faux poulets
frits totalement génial c'est dans le
fond les poulets est substitué par un
champignon une la pleurote dans le fond
qui donne vraiment laid la texture est
du poulet ont suffi le chat mais qui
prend tout le goulet l'apanage donc
c'est ce qui crée l'illusion c'est un
peu le futur de l'alimentation depuis
quelques années on parle de moins
consommer de viande puis c'est tout
naturel de vouloir exploiter ce
répertoire le
stelio perombelon et professeur de
cuisine ali thq il est responsable pour
la deuxième année du nouveau programme
de cuisine végétalienne ce d'exploiter
toutes les avenues sans les produits qui
proviennent des animaux essayer de se
pencher sur la teneur en protéines en
fibres et de l'incorporer vraiment dans
la nourriture de réfléchir à tout seul
lorsqu'on conçoit une assiette n'importe
quelle institution de cuisine va parler
de l'histoire de la cuisine et de ce qui
se fait dans le monde je pense que c'est
la première fois qu'on parle du futur de
la cuisine
[Musique]
il prépare une assiette de produits
classiques la brouillade de tofu
du tofu ferme égrainé ressemble à une
oeuvre ou y ont même public aidé avec le
curcuma ou on peut mettre un peu de
caries ou
pour le colorer un peu comme pour les
oeufs brouillés l'oeil un petit peu de
latitude quand même c'est pas très
rigide
au four pendant ce temps puis le
phobique n les mains se tranche de tofu
son mari né dans une préparation sucrée
salée avec de la fumée liquide c'est
vraiment de la fumée qui par
condensation aurait coûté juste les lic
et d'après qui est imprégnée lui de
teurgoule le sucre vol caramélisées puis
la marinade va entrer dedans et à la fin
on voit quelque chose de très près du
véhicule mais pour nous c'est une façon
de rassembler les gens autour d'un repas
et donc en étant vegan des fonds avec la
seule personne dans la famille qui et
vegan lui d'avoir une attitude qui
ressemble à quelque chose depuis que la
fixe a pu faire découvrir à des gens qui
auraient pas un effarement oser l rpv
gagnent ça nous est décrit une
gastronomique et inclusive on n'est pas
obligé de punir de s'unir pour aller au
restaurant végétalien si on a une demi
vie italien
pour faire des crêpes et des gaufres
aéré athéna substitut le blanc d'oeuf
par du vinaigre de cidre et de la poudre
à pâte le chef lui utilise des graines
de lin et des boissons végétales on
pourrait remplacer le lait par une
boisson végétale du les tuyaux du lait
d'avoine du lait d'amande ça marcherait
bien pile 9v quand on va le remplacer
moi j'aime bien faire le mucilage
graines de lin c'est à dire que je fais
me jeter un peu de graines de lin avec
de l'eau quelques minutes une quinzaine
de minutes mais ensuite eux soit
j'obtiens une espèce go gélatineuse à
partir de son jeu le filtre puis je
garde offrir aux friches dacom système
du blanc d'oeuf
principe existait des jeux que j'ai pu
m'inspirer donc ça a été quand même
assez faciles à faire ça peut avoir la
super compliqué mais c'est pas si
difficile que ça
c'est juste qu'on est tellement habitué
à penser qu'une omnivore que on trouve
ça difficile mais si on y met le même
temps que de préparer mais mettons un
boeuf bourguignon là on va avoir un
aussi beau pull pour amélie je pensais
être vegam à la base c'était pour
l'environnement mais tandis que master
plus pour le côté animal
le bien être animal l'environnement la
santé sont toutes des raisons d'adopter
cette alimentation ici la philosophie va
jusqu'aux décors les photos sur les murs
sont des animaux sauver de l'abattage on
n'est pas égal parce qu'on n'aimait pas
le goût de la viande ni vegan parce
qu'on a mais pas que l'animal soit tu es
donc c'est sûr que si on peut reproduire
quelque chose qui a le même goût aux
presque de ce qu'on aime et on va le
créer donnent ce qu'ils ont grandi avec
certaines habitudes alimentaires on
développe certain goût aux textures et
tout ce dont je pense que le fait de
reproduire fallait un côté aussi qui est
sécurisant on peut être rassurant dans
la transition c'est peut-être la porte
d'entrée vers le végétalisme mais une
fois qu'on se serait libéré dessus moi
je pense que on va réfléchir comme il
faut et puis on pourra créer des choses
qui ont leur identité faut que ça reste
gourmand sa boîte végétale ou omnivore
mais à la fin est ce que c'est bon
ça va être bien de diversifier on parle
de ce depuis très très longtemps mais là
ce sera plus par obligation c'est tout
simplement parce qu'on en a envie
[Musique]